المكان حي الزيتون جنوبي غزه الزمان نهايه
سبتمبر عام 2000 اي قبل 23 عاما تحديدا
الطفل الفلسطيني محمد الدره يبطل في حضن
والده برصاص اسرائيلي على الهواء امام
مراه ومصنع العالم اجمع
مشهد تاريخي هز العالم كله واشعل احتجاجات
واسعه في كثير من الدول كان جمال دره
عائدا مع ابنه محمد من السوق عندما وجد
طريق منزلهمام مغلقا بسبب مواجهه بين شبان
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال ما دفعهما
لسلوك طريق فرعي لكن الاب وابنه فوجئ
بوابل من الرصاص يطلق هو عليهما الجيش
الاسرائيلي من كل اتجاه بشكل مفاجئ ودون
سابق انذار حاول الاب احتضان طفله
والاحتماء بجانب كتله اسمنتيه لكن دون
جدوى قتل محمد واصيب والده بجروح خطره
واصبح الطفل الدره احد اهم رموز الانتفاضه
الفلسطينيه الثانيه التي اندلعت انذاك قبل
يومين من استشهاده عندما اقتحم رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق ريال شارون
المسجد الاقصى
[موسيقى]
انتفاضه استمرت حتى عام 2005 استشهد
خلالها اكثر من اربعه الاف فلسطيني وجرح
نحو خمسين الفا بغض النظر على اهداف شارون
الانتخابيه فهو تاكد انه لم يكن يتمكن من
دخول باحات الحرم دون حمايه مئات العناصر
من جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم تتوقف
جريمه اسرائيل عند قتل محمد الدره ففي
الحرب على غزه عام 2008 قصفت منزل عائلتها
وفي حرب 2014 جددت قصف المنزل دون اي سبب